ende april wurde der bußgeldkatalog für
verkehrssünder massiv verschärft unter
anderem sollte ein fahrverbot gelten
wenn man innerorts mehr als 21 kilometer
oder außerorts 26 kilometer zu schnell
fährt die folge
massenhaft verärgerte autofahrer die
unter anderem eine petition zur
rücknahme der verschärfungen starteten
offensichtlich mit erfolg denn nun
rudert andreas scheuer zurück und will
die strafe mildern ist der
verkehrsminister eingeknickt vor der
autofahrerlobby das fragen wir uns auf
kosten von fußgängern und radfahrern
ja wir haben es ihnen gefragt im
interview eines ist jetzt nichts gegen
wien sondern es ist eine regelung wo
auch die experten sagen das ist
unverhältnismäßig
man muss ja feststellen wir hatten über
100 anträge im bundesrat
ich selber habe diese verschärfung an
dem punkt nicht vorgeschlagen sondern
das ist in dem verfahren einfach dann
abgestimmt worden und jetzt sieht man
halt die praktischen probleme auch und
das muss ja vom gesamtkonstrukt des
bußgeldkatalogs auch passen und
verhältnismäßig sein
und denkt man nur daran dass wir von 21
km h bis 50 km/h überschreitung ein
monat fahrverbot haben und diese große
spanne sieht man ja dass es keine
unterschiede mehr gibt deswegen wollen
wir wieder zur alten regelung hin und
diese zweimal fahrverbot je ein monat
immer holz und außerorts wieder in die
alte bewährte regelung bringen und dazu
brauchen wir mehrheiten der bundesländer
die dafür einstimmig abgestimmt haben
für die veränderung und jetzt müssen wir
schauen dass wir die mehrheiten schaffen
für die alte regierung ja der ein oder
andere von uns hat vielleicht schon ein
fahrverbot bekommen seit der einführung
der neuen regeln und hofft jetzt
vielleicht wird es einen gnadenerlass
geben
ja diese zeit wird natürlich jetzt auch
diskutiert was von der regelung 28
vierter
wo sie in kraft getreten ist bis zu dem
zeitpunkt ist wenn die alte regelung
wieder in kraft tritt da sind wir noch
nicht durch das prüfen wir noch mit den
bundesländern zusammen
aber trotzdem sind wir da im gespräch
die tendenz ist natürlich dass wenn wir
jetzt erst einmal mehrheiten schaffen in
den bundesländern
dass wir darüber reden wie wir jetzt
genau in diesem fall verfahren da kann
ich noch keine entwarnung geben sondern
die regelung gilt die ist am 28.4 in
kraft getreten und politik muss auch
kraftvoll darin sein wenn wir viele
bürger zuschriften haben viele argumente
auch der bürger aufnehmen der experten
aufnehmen dass wir das wieder in das
alte verfahren zurück bringen und dazu
mehrheiten schaffen
das ist politik es bleibt immer auch ein
thema der veränderung also keine
entwarnung für schon überführte
temposünder aber wenigstens ein
hoffnungsschimmer und natürlich wollten
wir auch wissen wofür der minister
selbst sein letztes knöllchen bekommen
hat falschparken und wie teuer war dass
ich glaube 15 euro
ja politiker sind auch menschen